happy new year
[Music]
well folks if you're watching this that
means
you did make it to the end of 2020
or at least the last day of it
just get over the finish line but this
will be coming out
on december 31st of garbage fire year
2020. and i wanted to do
sort of my recap of the past
year and look ahead to the next one
specifically in regards to the channel
i am going to be putting out something
uh next week which will have my picks
for the best
pieces of entertainment i had to expand
beyond just movies because
you know the world happened but
um this one's going to be about
what my last year has been like the
ups the downs mostly i'm going to talk
positive but obviously there are
negatives to
acknowledge and i'm going to talk a bit
about what my hopes
for the next year are and i kind of want
to get the
downside stuff a bit out of the way so
that it's not
going to dominate too much of this
obviously everything that has gone on
with covid has been frankly kind of a
disaster and a nightmare and
i have been fortunate to
um to the best of my knowledge
not have lost any family members
specifically to this illness
but i do have friends who have
and even if that hasn't happened this
has obviously impacted
your life and all our lives and very
negative ways
and well beyond the superficial thing of
oh a bunch of movies got pushed back
like yeah that sucks but big picture
so obviously there was that um i
said i had family members who didn't um
succumb to that disease and the best of
my knowledge that's true
however i did lose a few family members
this year i lost
an aunt out in california and i lost my
father
this year and i was not able to
um go and spread his ashes
because of this pandemic i uh
we had to pay a stranger to take
his ashes out and spread them at sea
which is what he wanted
and i couldn't be there i had the uh
the dubious honor of being the subject
of a
blaire white video this year
we've had way more celebrities
stepping in it specifically in returns
to
trans and lgbtq plus issues than i would
care to go over but obviously the big
one
being jk rowling
none of this stuff uh helped
with this year it really didn't one
thing you'll notice isn't on that list
of things that were bad though
is the fact that i lost my job
you'd think that would have been a bad
thing but here's the
here's the second act twist
losing that job was one of the best
things to happen to me in
years
i wow i was gonna say i've been unhappy
at the job for a long time i
never loved that job it had gotten worse
over the last three four years but
it was never what i wanted to be doing
this is what i wanted to be doing
and when i lost the job
and i made that information public and
in a
what i thought was going to come across
as a very desperate bid
asking if more people could support me
on patreon
people did
this is my job now
that's insane and
amazing the fact that i get to get up in
the morning
and do something i love
and it is what pays my bills barely
it's tight if i'm going to be completely
honest i haven't still haven't quite hit
the financial goals that i would like to
but i can cover my bills i'm not in
danger of losing anything
the car the house nothing's getting shut
off i
i can feed myself i can't feed my kid
everything's covered it is
very tight but it is covered
that's incredible
and i cannot thank everybody
enough everyone who supported me
everyone who watches
this channel whether you subscribe or
not if you don't subscribe hit the
hit that i'd appreciate it but seriously
if you are watching this thank you
thank you that
shift has been one of the most positive
things to happen in my life in years
i have not enjoyed
my day-to-day life the things that i've
had to spend
eight hours a day doing for a
long time and now i do and that is
incredible
bringing it in terms of the channel
itself
uh growth wasn't quite what i would have
liked to have seen this year
um i was hoping to break 50k this year
that didn't happen
um it has still been growing the channel
continues to grow and that's great
and i'm still and i'm grateful for for
all of that
um hoping to get things
moving and picking up a little bit next
year but we'll see
that's the sort of thing that normally
would have bummed me out but you know i
just look back at the fact that this is
my
job but i'm like okay growth wasn't
quite what i wanted i'm still
okay i'm still really happy um
and you know looking at
i was gonna look at you know what my
most
viewed stuff was except my
four most viewed videos were all ones of
me being either angry or frustrated
uh one of them was about the timeless
children
and the other three were either about
directly or and somehow
circled on the subject of jk rowling and
i
neither want to discuss those things
anymore nor memorialize them so instead
let me talk about some of the
video projects that i did this year that
i'm most proud of i'm
actually really proud of the watchman
video that went up earlier this month
which is doing better than i thought it
would
usually my passion projects like that
um don't do well and i wasn't
expecting this one to but it's doing
good it's about average for me and
honestly given that most of the stuff
that i sing a lot of time into in our
heavy edit jobs tank
just being average i'm quite happy with
that but i'm really proud of that
i'm really really proud of
how to fix ghostbusters 2. that's
probably the most elaborate
um shoot definitely
possibly one of the more most elaborate
edits i've had to do
um i say had brought it on myself
i'm actually i'm i'm proud of
all the lgbtq plus related stuff that i
did this year
but honestly the thing that i might be
most proud of that's sort of
tangentially related to that i'm
really proud of the positive masculinity
video
i'm really really proud of that
um with the the video itself and just
just getting able being able to talk
about that topic i was really happy with
and also speaking of passion projects
that tanked
um 90s comics retrial came back i proved
that i have figured out how to use my
green screen correctly
nobody watched it but that's okay
um i am still actually really proud of
that video the views were low enough
that i don't know
when i'll do another one like it but i
am still
quite proud of that stepping outside the
channel
um i
started estrogen this year it's
actually it's been almost a year now
because i started in january
and i am um
quite happy with the results
announced a pronoun change which
went over very well and everyone was
very supportive about
just before everything locked down i got
to go to gallifrey one
in los angeles the doctor who convention
and that was amazing
i'd never been before i got to
meet i say meat it's not like we're not
friends and we could like but i got to
meet
and shake the hands of and say it to
them in person what their work meant to
me christopher eccleston
fraser hines peter davison pearl mackey
i got to meet riley silverman who is
someone i've known and respected
um for ages i got to meet jesse gender
she wasn't even at
the convention but she was still living
in l.a at the time we grabbed coffee
and i can now actually safely say
jesse's a friend
and we started a podcast together the
what the foul podcast talking about
firescape which is a show i love it like
had no reason to talk about it now i get
to talk about it again with someone i'm
getting to help
introduce to it i met a lot of amazing
people there i got to meet
carowind if you folks ever
are on my live streams she's one of the
mods
i got to meet her in person and that was
wonderful
i'm so grateful that that experience and
that convention
came in under the wire before everything
started
to get closed down that
that gave me a lot of energy that i kind
of rode through
at least about a month after that on i
had a successful
kickstarter for my novel actually
scarily
successful i raised over double what i
was asking
which honestly kind of terrifies me
also i'll circle back to that a little
bit when i start talking about
future for the channel on a whim
i started messing around on tiktok
and i now at time of recording have over
76
000 followers i have more followers on
tick tock
than i have on all three of my active
youtube channels
combined
don't ask i don't understand
i'm having fun with it but what i feel
like i'm stumbling into success somehow
on that which is
nice i guess um
i was lucky enough to get a few
sponsorships across this year
from both larger and smaller
organizations or services or products
and uh while i'm hopeful to have more
things like that because it helps
it helps me maybe start to build up a
savings again because
i don't have a lot i don't have much of
a safety net right now
but we'll see where the future is as far
as that goes
and i suppose that should lead me into
talking about the future
in general now by and large do not
expect major changes to this channel
going into 2021 i
intend and want to keep things
on the path that i'm on right now the
one big
question mark for me right now is
what will happen once i'm done with the
take two doctor who reviews
because those should wrap up um
later this year even if i decide to do
series 11 and 12. i'm i'll probably do
series 11.
um i think enough time has passed that
that's worth revisiting i'm not sure i'm
up for
revisiting series 12 already i'll decide
on that but even if i do both of those
i will have caught up by
um well before the end of this year or
several months to go
and right now i don't know
if i'm going to put anything else in
that slot
purely logically it would make sense for
me to say start doing
torchwood episode by episode or sarah
jane adventures or
start putting uh classic doctor who
reviews there or big finish or just keep
reviewing doctor who stuff
in that wednesday slot just not have to
be the take two reviews anymore
and i'm reluctant to start doing that
because the simple truth is my doctor
who material
when doctor who is not airing new
episodes
it it doesn't get the views anymore and
the and the overdue doctor who review
series now the take two doctor who
review series those views have been
dropping
over time and it's a pretty safe
assumption for me to
make that if my revisiting the main
series that everyone knows
is getting not awful but
lower end of my normal
for views the spin-offs
are gonna do even less now that's not to
say that i will never talk about twitter
sarah jane adventures or whatever
but i'm simply saying that the episode
by episode format is probably a bad idea
for me because unfortunately one of the
side effects of this being my job now is
i do have to keep an eye on the
analytics a bit more
and on a regular basis continually
putting out stuff that doesn't garner a
lot of views
doesn't help the channel it actually
hinders it it's arguable that my that at
this point with the way things
have declined the way they have i might
be
damaging my growth by seeing take two
doctor who reviews through to the end
but i'm still going to because i'm
stubborn like that but
in the interest of channel growth i'm
really hesitant to slide uh
some other variant of doctor who reviews
as a weekly thing into that wednesday
slot
so once i finish that i don't know if
there will be anything that
that goes there and i may end up doing
one video a week as a result
that's some months down the line so i do
have time to think about that
but i would like to think it would free
me up to
potentially do more reliably
one big project a month because that was
kind of my hope
um going down to two videos that for the
saturday stuff the premiere
material um i could have
one video a month that would be
something on the scale of the watchmen
video
that didn't happen while i had a few
videos of that size and scope
they were not once a month i think i
might have a better chance of doing
that if i was only if i only had one
video a week
but i again i don't know i'm not sure
yet that having been said i mentioned
the book
so priority one
going into january is for me to finish
the dang edit on the book
because i want to get it out and
available
i'm gonna the line i'm gonna say i want
it out and available and
for purchase before my birthday so
that's march
so that gives me enough time to work
with i think
but i really
need to focus on that so that again
that's not going to diminish how many
videos
there are per week on this channel nor
does it mean that the break room of
geeks is going to go dead
of course that one doesn't have an
actual upload schedule anyway but what
it does mean is
do not expect anything of the size and
scale of say the watchmen
video until
probably april because i need to
really get stuck in on the book get it
done
get it finalized and get it printed
and then honestly i need to catch up on
commissioned reviews
because i have a backlog of those um
and i really feel bad about how far
behind i am on those
so even after i've i've got the book set
to go
i'm probably going to take at least a
month to try and put a dent
into my backlog of commission reviews
and to try and catch up on those
so again we're probably looking at april
before i deal with
with something as ambitious as the
watchmen video
but that stuff will be coming again and
the reason it's going to be that kind of
gap is because of other things that i
either am doing or should have done like
the fact that the commission review is
backed up that's my own fault but i do
still need time to clear it
and the book that's obviously something
i've been working at a long time
and we'll see how the book does i don't
have
huge ambitions for sales numbers but
that is potentially
one more stream of revenue which will
help it's
it's been such a weird year for
more than the obvious reasons because
for as
awful as so much of what's gone on has
been
my personal and definitely my
professional
and much of my personal life
has been great
and as a thank you for that
i'm going to do something that i've
never done before
which is i'm going to read out the names
of my
patreon backers
and not just the ones who are currently
supporting me
all of them every single
name that has ever supported me on
patreon
whether it was for one month or for all
the time that i've been on there
because i could not be where i am right
now
without you and i think i got everybody
down
i'm really paranoid that i somehow
missed one and if i do
i'm so so sorry but we're gonna try this
and i don't know if i'll ever do it
again
but the main thing that went
right for me this year is because of you
and you deserve a thank you and just for
fun
i'm going to read these in the opposite
order that you are currently seeing them
so a very special thanks
to zenbri zaphod2073
yamp 44 zandir
william roche william paxton
wendy bunton vincent paul bartolucci
victoria thomas victor smith
vicki houston van west
ulrich feint ulysses
trevor isherwood tracy scrabbit
tracy pell tracy dale
tracy brumskin toy lowly
tourist investor guard tony saunders
tommy castronova tommy hortana
thomas nice wand thomas fireheart
the one rick the doctor
the bugger boo the blessed reign
terry stevens terry nils
ted tammy stapleton
tay hallett stephen j
seidler spark of ziyug
smurfing rail fan jedi
sentinel sierra n ellison
sheila moore shayla
gourlay shannon de respino
severin t crammer sebastian
glemser sataria george
sriracha sarah parker shemelt
sarah hamilton sarah g
sam sam
ross schultz ross riley
robin moore reflective rambling
real life jolie ray wood
ransom campbell randy thompson
rachel loretto rachel amatrano
quite awkward pop icarus
poker pope plisskin 1997
phillip hawkins peter christopher
patrick niemeyer
marie ny angel 79
newb hemingway knightseeker07
nicole mazza nick hopper
nick coffin nick
never lose neil mulholland
natasha haikini mysterious ways 143
moa larson moa halt
mld irish 14
missy mcpeek mira g
mike minton miguel gonzalez
michelle c funk michelle jones
michael reindell michael
melita melinda walters
megan j megan
matthew the edgehead gould mad tazzy man
martin pakes marjorie shepard
maria kowal malu jensen
mayloran maddie j
maram debone
lisa lydia tareen
luke tonkinson luck fair
luigi camp lucy wood
lorna pottinger laura reloaded
little sister lisa sabar
lisa casey lil churley
libby cohen liam hennigan
lexi lee
leah flanagan latoya pastor
larry irby lalomi
kyle leader claudia zamanska
kirsty haken kim lewis
keiki kaylee wilson
katherine blay kathleen spore
katherine kaye kate rajacki
ledem kai
judah jules harvell
julianna rigel julie bro
jude fahrenheit josh hendry
joseph gresham jorgen peterson
jonathan bruns jonathan
john ryan john hibler
john gerber john dent
john belcher joel savage
joel catherine's joel
joe pranovich joe
batsford j.m atwood
jesse grabow jessica donnelly reed
jenna the fan girl jay finlayson
jasper tree jason palette
janina suregout janna
james rodabaugh james p
james johnson james hall
jamie heather jade ellis
jacob solstice jack warren
isabel quinones isabelle lovelace
emma delkey holly dunn
helen yang haiki binsak
hannah collette hannah poole
hamish spence greg gillum
giovanni dimaggio
general contact unit problem child
gary hicks galafreya
gail mackey fernabulax the poodle
frida bertelsen ava bright
aaron o'connell erica summerfeld
emma lou mf emma jarvis
emily rauch elizabeth cherry owen
elizabeth hobbes elijah handley
eli bergmas edward phillips
edward badour ed thomas
doctor who rush dr gunn
diana debbie dearest
dead riot david chu david cheater
dave weston dark lily
danny gibson daniel leach
daniel e jacobs dancing man promotions
dalam reviews corey
wilmarth colin graham
clark trantham claritz bell
flores clara finn handley
christopher poff chris
carline chris bachman
charlie spears charleston
rat cell specs
kailyn schwartz katherine bazani
casper carpe librarium
kari kelly skye kara watson
captain woodlaws calum ray
caleb cadence
bronze wool britney moore
brian delaney brian beza
bookworm bex scott
benjamin beatrix purvis
beatmaster barbara albert
ashley maxwell ashen hale
arthur gatward anthony fisher
anthony daly anna miller
anna kozena angus bjarnsen
angry casperl ange brooks
angela www andy
sonnox andrew kellner
amanda mccoy alicia
lieberman alex
alhanna escher alex schuler
alex cars alex hope
alex elisa kuiper
al griffith adrian enfield
adam thornton adam parker
adam lefty taylor adam appel
ace of thorns abigail mason
abigail knowles abby mason
aaron mcnamara aardvark 12
and at quinn demand
thank you and have a happy new year
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh